Hi I'm Michelle and I have a blog called
Lab Muffin. Today I'm going to be
talking about why pH matters for alpha
hydroxy acids and vitamin C. There are
many acidic active ingredients in
skincare: alpha hydroxy acids like
glycolic, lactic and malic acids; beta
hydroxy acid or salicylic acid; vitamin C
or L-ascorbic acid; hyaluronic acid,
retinoic acid and many more. You might
have heard that some acid products need
to be a certain pH to work. Why is that?
Here's the science behind the skin care tip.
Acids are molecules that can give up
hydrogen ions or H+. For example, sulfuric
acid or battery acid is H2SO4,
hydrochloric acid in your stomach is HCl,
and acetic acid in vinegar is CH3COOH.
All of them can break up to give up
hydrogen ions like so. You can see that
the acids in skincare also have hydrogen
that can break off.
The top layer of the skin, the stratum
corneum, is made up of cells embedded in
oily lipids much like bricks in mortar.
Oil is non-polar, which means it isn't
charged, while water is polar, which means
it's partially charged. According to the
rule of thumb for solubility "like
dissolves like" - that is, things that are
uncharged like to mingle with
things that are also uncharged, but
they'll repel things that are charged.
This means that in general, charged
particles will not get into skin easily.
When acids haven't given up their
hydrogen ions they're uncharged so
they're able to penetrate the stratum
corneum. The uncharged version is called
the free acid. But if they've broken up
or dissociated into a hydrogen ion and
a negatively charged anion, they're too
polar to get through the non-polar
stratum corneum very easily. The extent
to which the acid is broken up depends
on a few things. Let's talk about the two
that are most important in skincare.
First, the strength of the bond holding
the hydrogen ion to the rest of the
acid. This is measured by something
called the pKa of the acid. For example
hydrochloric acid has a very low pKa, so
in water-based solutions it's almost
100% broken up. Acetic acid on
the other hand has a much higher pKa
so in water only about 1 in 100 acidic
hydrogens have broken off. We call this
strong and weak. Skincare acids are all
weak acids so they're varying amounts of
broken up. Secondly there's also the pH
of the overall product. pH measures the
total concentration of hydrogen ions and
low pH means more hydrogen. The hydrogen
ions can come from the skincare acid or
from other acids added to the mixture.
Let's consider a product where half the
acid molecules are in the free acid form so
half can get into the skin. If the pH is
lower, there's more hydrogen ions around,
which means more will attach onto the
acid molecules giving more of the
uncharged free acid, which can penetrate.
This means that a lower concentration of
acid at a lower pH will give the
equivalent amount of free acid as a
higher concentration at a higher pH. For
example, a product with 10%
glycolic acid at pH 3 would have
8.7% of the product
in uncharged form, whereas at pH 4.5
you'd need 50% glycolic acid
to get a similar amount. In summary, low
pH will always increase the amount of
uncharged acid that will penetrate the
skin, and the pH required to get a high
concentration of uncharged acid depends
on which acid we're talking about. Why
not use a super low pH then? You'd be
correct in thinking that if we used a
really low pH that would give us the
maximum amount of uncharged acid that
could penetrate. Unfortunately, skin likes
to be at around pH 5 and very low pH can
cause chemical burns.
For leave-on products, it's recommended that
you use alpha hydroxy acids at a pH of
less than four and a concentration
between 4 and 10 percent, and ascorbic
acid at a pH of around 3.5 and a
concentration between 5 and 20 percent.
What about the other acids? It gets more
complex here because the rest of the
acid molecule makes a big difference.
Hyaluronic acid is a large polymer made
up of thousands of these units, so it's
way too big to get into the skin anyway.
And it doesn't need to - it's a humectant
moisturizer which means it sits on top
of skin and holds on to water to keep
your skin moist. For retinoic acid, the
rest of the molecule is non-polar enough
that the charge doesn't make a big
difference. For salicylic acid or beta
hydroxy acid it's often recommended that
you use a product with a pH of less than
3.5 and a concentration of 1-2%
but there's some evidence that
it's also non-polar enough that pH
doesn't matter. That's a quick
introduction to pH and acids in
skincare. I definitely haven't covered
everything because delivering things
through skin is a huge huge topic. I hope
you found this video useful, and if you'd
like to see more videos like this from
me in the future, please comment and let
me know!